let's go at our reject nation Greg Elbe
here so this trailer came out for a
movie starring Thomas the cruise one of
my favorite actors ever apparently it's
directed by Doug Liman I'd never heard
of his movie does Lyman as you know
director of a lot of big films Bourne
Identity mr. and mrs. Smith edge of
tomorrow also starring Tom Cruise
swingers the wall this movie's called
American made and today I'm going to do
a picture of the day shadow to one of
our latest members of our patreon
community andrew Terpening so that'll be
at the end of the video keep a look
after that no speeding around the tushie
let's watch this the United States Drug
Enforcement Agency
we're ordering into last night let's
land
[Music]
Wow my name is Barry seal that's for
damage for your sister
hallo darlin and your bike somebody [ __ ]
really happen ha ha you never saw me
shut up your class in Civil Air Patrol
like you shouldn't be flying saucers of
them I am
welcome to Bakersfield have you ever
wanted something more Barry you should
be serving your country you're CIA
why we need you to deliver stuff for us
oh is it later if you're doing it for
the good guys
very sealed a goddamn genius Wow airline
pilot Barry that's how disappointed
family it's gonna be good for us
[Music]
trust me Oh Danny operated very marriage
[Music]
Roscoe does this up in the backyard or
still blown around everywhere
sorry get up in the morning how come
you're developing caddies have more on
space than any other car I mean each and
every one of you the caddies your
troubles time to walk out of here kids
already dancing anyway you can do about
it we should have taken a case
[Music]
I was working for the CIA the DEA and
hablo eskimo genious escudos that's 15
like the undertale apart in bordeaux get
it done I don't think he ran once in
that whole trailer he kind of skipped a
little bit when he crashing the plane
and then took that kids bike you know
any movie I was just talking with John
about this I think two days ago most
movies not all movies and most movies
that have the word American at the
beginning tend to be about the
corruption of the American Dream you
know they were you reached you far you
go down a road of corruption and
debauchery greed greed is so much fun in
these movies what I'm really excited for
is that Tom Cruise is not doing this not
an action movie I mean every once in a
while he does a movie the where he's not
doing any action like Tropic Thunder and
he did that one movie I think Lions for
lambs I think with Robert Redford and
Meryl Streep Tom Cruise he's a fantastic
actor and I feel like that you know he's
one of our best action stars that we
have around today I think it's really
neat that he's doing this film that is a
biopic where it's just not an action
film it's just a full-on performance it
still has that Tom Cruise charm he's
smiling through like 90% of this trailer
and Tom Cruise smile is amazing man that
guy he's a just so well he looks so
freakin handsome I can't believe and oh
and didn't make the joke didn't make the
joke that I know everyone else is making
this one maverick is doing after Top Gun
huh funny because he's a pilot in the
movie they're hilarious
and the doug liman direction the
cinematography his felt you know he
doesn't always use handheld but whenever
he does have his shots handheld it looks
like the does Lyman type of handheld
cinematography I know the credit goes to
cinematographer as well I do like these
kind of stories of you know the
corruption of the American dream you
know wolf of wallstreet lord of war even
get some more dogs live in here
it goes in there for sure Pablo Escobar
easily the coolest drug lord of all time
weird to say but you know he's like
component a lot of ways he's like that
drug lord
it's kind of cool for some reason and I
think I can get my hair to some days my
hair so curly enough where I could look
like a Pablo Escobar I'm wondering is
this the kind of film thing is coming
around I think it's coming out during
this fall I'm wondering is this kind of
film where they're trying to get Tom
Cruise to get an Oscar nomination it
doesn't really seem like they're pushing
for Oscar nomination here because yeah
it's a biopic however it looks more of
the umbrella of a comedic vibe
throughout it looks really funny and
entertaining it doesn't look like a
super serious biopic I mean it's been a
long time since Tom Cruise has been
nominated for anything but like I say
he's gone down this path where he's
doing a lot of action films because that
seems to be the thing ever since all
that big Scientology the toggle jumping
on Oprah Winfrey's couch you know
talking about Brooke Shields all that
crap that happened it seems that's the
thing that's kept his career alive is
doing a lot of action films it's cool to
see you doing a film that is just going
to really test this dramatic chops again
you know because some of my favorite
performances of Tom Cruise like born on
the fourth of July and Jerry Maguire
even way back when - the color of money
and these five things tend to have the
typical structure of setup of how they
get inside the drug business and then
it's like the first half is all fun and
games it's a really good time and then
at the midpoint enforcement authorities
start honing and start trying to take
him down things are getting darker you
know less fun the relationship probably
starts to crumble and by the end of it
he gets God already you know goes to the
witness protection program or something
either way this is one of those stories
it's about a journey not about the end
result because obviously being a biopic
I could just Wikipedia who this guy is
and find out the whole story there or
maybe there's a biography book out there
that I could read but this is one of
those stories that is about the journey
and I like seeing these kind of movies
because it always has the same effect on
me where the first half of it I'm going
now I would I would love to get into the
drug business just looks like a bunch of
debauchery and fun and then my day and
I'm like I you know it's a good thing
I'm going down a legal path and of
course one of the other be stories of it
will be the relationship that he has
with his wife and Matias Kong she's
smoking and I'm kind of curious to see
how they hone in on that relationship
because it looks
a devoted husband and father in this
story because a lot of his time from
these biopics you find out oh this guy
got into a lot of money they started
cheating on his woman a lot they didn't
hint it down think so there's a lot of
images here then hint that he be cheats
on his wife and on and that might be the
character quality that they hone in on
that well at least he's a good dad
though and he's a good devoted husband
but that's why we like him because
they're like the tuchas whatever the
wife or the spouse you know really
learns what her husband is really all
about all the drug stuff all the illegal
things he's doing but starts to fall
into the fund as well of it and starts
to enjoy all of it as well so this one
wasn't look entirely original to me
something tells me it's going to follow
the same beat sheet of a lot of these
types of biopics however it looks like a
strong Tom Cruise performance it looks
really funny looks really entertaining
doug liman i love how he's one of those
directors who does a lot of huge
Hollywood films but every once in a
while like he did the wall recently so
he takes a break to you know hone in and
do one of his smaller films on his indie
films and then go back to a big one
because I know right now he's gearing up
to do live die repeat and repeat just
call it edge of tomorrow - what the hell
yeah looks like a really entertaining
flick excited to see Tom Cruise just do
a roll or you'll get primarily just
recognized for doing damn good acting
all right guys thanks for tuning in you
can subscribe it the real rejects get
accepted into the reject nation and
click that notification about to get
notified whatever one of our videos is
out follow me at the Greg owl on
Instagram and Twitter I actually use
those and of course the patient of the
day shout out to Andrew to taringa tank
Andrew to Terpening Terpening this guy
recently joined our patreon you made a
rather large pledge and I'm so happy
you're part of the community Andrew he
actually sent me a very flattering
message so hey you guys love what you do
helps me pass the time when I'm gone
that's all our channels good for it's a
good filler it's a good passer so I
appreciate the extra attention to the
compliment there I just want to support
what you guys are doing so thank you
Andrew Terpening I want to support you
for supporting us
help me help you keep the Tom Cruise by
goke and Andrew I looked up what your
name means it means manling
that means manly will add you there's
nothing more manly than two men both
going at it you know it's not it's not
real man to go up to a woman approach or
try to sleep with her no that's not a
real man that's for [ __ ] you and I
Andrew we're going to get manlier than
ever that's what I do for people who
pledge hi on patreon I insist that we
have gay man Lea sex feel my stare feel
it feel I'm Andrew
and your name Terpening means someone
who lives at a house distinguished by
the sign of a coin I have nothing to go
off of there